unemployment's gonna be very ugly
Bloomberg just came out yesterday saying
100 chance next year it's going to be
recession Warren Buffett two years ago
when he was sitting on 125 billion
dollars of cash everybody called him
crazy right now he's sitting on 105
billion dollars of cash why would he sit
on 105 billion dollars of cash 2024 the
day after election the next day will be
the single biggest climb ever to doubt
in a history of America it's going to go
to the roof the next 18 to 24 months is
not going to be pretty for Content
creators it's the complete opposite of
what I just said
thanks for coming back on the podcast
fired up to get into the content we got
the economy to uh talk about macro
economy the Creator economy and I want
to hear about content strategy how
you're thinking about content how you're
thinking about all of that stuff but
this is a special interview because
today is your birthday yes it is and
you're here at work
how do you feel about your mentality
when it just comes to hustle working on
your birthday being devoted to your
vision what's it mean to you in this
moment on your birthday to be doing a
podcast here at valuetainment
headquarters I I don't mean to you know
like undermine it but it means literally
nothing it's just another work day but
here's why a long time ago uh when I
started building my business I asked I
said so if I'm somebody that takes
vacation based on what the government
tells me
then I'm just like everybody else I said
I don't want the government to tell me
when is a vacation I don't want their
traditional days to be vacation I want
me to choose when I want to go on
vacation whatever those days may be
so Christmas to me extremely valuable I
over invest spent for Christmas because
it's a my favorite holiday of the year
uh birthdays that's 44 44 I mean it's a
Reggie Jackson's number 44 Jim Brown you
know you got Nolan Ryan and 44 is a cool
number but it's nothing crazy about it I
think 45 will do a party I'm probably
not going to do anything from 46 to 49
and at 50 we're going to do something
that's going to be pretty legendary but
yeah in regards to today being a
birthday and me being at work this is
very very if you ask my wife who's
somewhere around here we just had lunch
we went and looked at the other building
real quick this has been the story of my
life I'm the guy that ran sales meetings
on Labor Day weekend where everybody's
taking Monday off I have a 6 a.m sales
meeting you know I'm the guy that you
know December 31st everybody is partying
until late at night January 1st I got an
eight o'clock sales meeting I'm that
weird guy that ran those meetings
because I just felt you know if it's a
psyche if it's whatever you want to call
it I wanted to do what others don't want
to do on certain days and I want to
teach willpower to myself and others I
thought that's what it took to win and
whether I'm right or wrong it's worked
out I love it so you spoke at our event
grow a video live and You Came Out
Swinging you're about to talk about
content but you were like listen uh
warning you know you got to get ready
for the next 24
36 months we could be facing the
greatest economic crash reset and
recently at your conference the Vault
you had Robert Kiyosaki come on and he
spoke at your event and he said we are
about to face the biggest economic crash
in history and it's still coming it's
the everything bubble my question for
you is have you updated your point of
view over the last few months do you
think things are going to be better
worse in the middle and even you made
some predictions about housing all of
the above what's kind of the current
state of the economy from your
perspective and some of the things
you're personally doing housing is going
to still take a massive hit it's not
over with uh you know the luxury housing
market dropped 28 percent which that's a
problem right there and the way they
Define the luxury housing market is like
the top two percent in any City so you
know top two percent in New York could
be a you know 20 million Auto home but a
top two percent in Toledo could be an
800 000 home it doesn't matter imagine
the luxury Market dropped 28 in six
months so a 10 million dollar house was
a 7.8 million dollar house a million
dollar has a 720 000 house 7.2 million
dollar house so that's a big number
right there uh loan officers are leaving
the industry by the droves Realtors are
leaving the industry buy the droves
you're looking at Licensing in the state
of Texas is down Licensing in the state
of California is down you're seeing
what's going on with the economy right
now where it's kind of okay season right
now it's like oh it's good it's recovery
it's not recovery uh the Powell's talked
about the fact that they're going to
raise interest rates until inflation
it's two percent inflation is still
eight percent which means rates are
going to go 30-year mortgage rates just
cracked seven percent a year ago you
could have gotten a 30 year mortgage
rate at 2.65 2.85 that's a big
difference when you think about the the
payment so the only thing that happens
when rates are high values down when
rates are low values are up the mortgage
payments the same thing it doesn't
matter so the mortgage payment on a
million dollar home at seven percent is
the same as the mortgage of a say
million three home at two percent or at
three percent so nothing's changing in
regards to monthly payment that I can
afford rates are going up so value has
to go down so there's going to be a lot
of people that are still sitting on
their homes trying to sell it they won't
do it by the way I'll give you a
personal story on how I lost a hundred
thousand dollars in a car the last 12
months okay so my Ferrari was on sale a
year ago I don't want to keep the
Ferrari because I couldn't fit in it a
little less than a year ago it's an sf90
it's a beautiful car I put in in the
market for 800 000 I got a 765 offer I
said no I'm not going to sell for 7.65.
there's only a couple of these in the
market I'm gonna get my 800 personal
experience I'm telling you about right
okay Mr genius so this 799 car that I
turned down 765. three months later I
called the guy back said no I'll give
you 700 I said no
so then I got a 720 off right turned
down I got a 710 off right turned down I
got a 700 000 I turned down and I'm
getting 685 offers I'm turning down what
do you think is going to end up
happening it's going down but it's
dropped itself a hundred thousand
dollars 120
000 is just sitting on it so from
personal experience this is not going to
slow down and what they're pushing for
the one number that they're still
looking at that no one's you know so
well look at this unemployment is very
strong unemployment's gonna be very ugly
Q2 of next year it is not going to be
pretty Bloomberg just came out yesterday
saying 100 chance next year it's going
to be recession it was it was like 56 or
60 they just bumped it up to 100 uh
Jamie diamonds it's going to be pretty
ugly uh everybody you talk to is not
looking too pretty right now matter of
fact while this is going on a guy that
many May recognize his name is Warren
Buffett we all know who he is David
Rubinstein just wrote a book called how
to invest phenomenal book and he's
interviewing everybody Larry Fink Great
Value this money he's interviewing all
the great ones and everybody gives
credit to one guy Warren Buffett well
Warren Buffett right now
two years ago when he was sitting on 125
billion dollars of cash everybody called
him crazy
right now he's sitting on 105 billion
dollars of cash why would he sit on 105
billion dollars of cash he knows
opportunity is going to come up he's
going to buy companies on Pennies on a
dollar then the legendary you know
Bridgewater you're talking uh uh uh Ray
dalio who five years ago was saying
Cash's trash just came out and says cash
is no longer trash cash is valuable
today you know you got to have cash
because opportunities are coming along
so it's going to be everything that I
said that I believe it was going to
happen it was going to happen now Dave
Ramsey who was beloved by a lot of
different people and he's very big in a
Christian Community and a lot of people
follow him I went to a church that we
would go take a Dave Ramsey course
that's kind of what she did if you went
to a church uh that wanted to have
somebody with credibility talk about
money and he would always give the basic
you know how to pay off your debt buy
term invest the difference all the basic
principles he said don't buy into this
fear porn that everyone's talking about
real estate is going to drop he said
this six or nine months ago I don't
think he's saying that right now because
real estate has taken a hit and it's not
going to be slowing down you got
inventory that's going up it's not going
to slow down when inventory I mean I can
go on and on and on telling you a bunch
of other things with the market I'm not
changing my position I think 2022 is
going to be uh
ugly but not that ugly I think 2023 is
going to be very very weird year for a
lot of people 2024 the day after
election the day we vote whatever the
day is 2024 November 3rd whatever that
Tuesday is the day we vote my prediction
the next day will be the single biggest
climb ever to doubt in a history of
America history of the market it's going
to go to the room my prediction I could
be wrong I believe 25 26 that was going
to get somewhere around 50 to 60 000 but
the next 18 to 24 months is not going to
be pretty so in light of your
predictions what is your advice for
entrepreneurs content creators right now
those that want to prepare and position
yourself what are a few moves they can
make to be very serious about right now
I mean for Content creators it's the
complete opposite of what what I just
said you know covid and the shutdown was
great for Content creators meet Kevin
came out of nowhere and all of a sudden
he had a million and a half cram
stepping went from I don't know he was
at four five hundred thousand Subs I
think he's at four million Subs now you
got a bunch of people that blew up
during covet because when people are
afraid they listen so when people are
afraid they need to be entertained so
when a person stressed out sometimes
they just want to watch a comedy film
they have no desire to watch a overly
you know scary you know let me tell you
what's going on with the market like
dude I just want to break just make me a
laugh you know so you notice when covet
hit what went to the roof alcohol went
to the roof beer companies went to the
roof liquor went to the roof
entertainment went to the roof tiger
king became a celebrity where he was
running for office not to be a president
who would have thought we're going to
watch Tiger King 64 million people are
going to log on to Netflix in the first
three weeks and watch Tiger King who's
Tiger King I was in Tiger King too I
don't even know I wasn't Tiger King too
I'm getting calls and Pat you realize
you're a tiger King too because I
interviewed one of the individuals from
Tiger King so now Joe Exotic is in jail
him and I message each other and he
follows the content but you you you
didn't know what was going to happen so
for Content creators if they position
themselves right in areas that people
want I think it's going to be a very
good season for Content creators who
position themselves the right way if I
personalize this a little bit we're so
inspired by what you've done with
valuetainment you've bought this
incredible building your podcast is in a
vault it's the Vault podcast it's a
former bank right and we're about to
tour it excited for that
um we want to buy a building in Las
Vegas and my wife and I also our current
house is so positioned to be an amazing
rental it will cash flow incredible the
mortgage is under three percent
um and we have more kids we want to
expand if you're me are you buying what
would be your timing on pursuing buying
commercial and buying a home I happen to
be in the market of Vegas it's a hot
spot it swings High swings low and then
we maybe brought in that advice maybe
somebody can relate to thinking about
expanding their business you just bought
a new building and so maybe dueling
mindsets of do we shrink back do we lean
in or what are some of the factors of
measuring these things yeah so uh I want
to say something some people are going
to not like it but it is what it is I
think it's a perfect season right now to
make disrespectful offers
say that one more time it's a perfect
season right now to make disrespectful
offers
a year and a half ago nobody had the
right to make disrespectful offers and
nobody cared if you made disrespectful
offers a person who made a disrespectful
offer a year and a half ago looked like
an idiot today a disrespectful offer
gets an attention so let's qualify what
is a disrespectful offer say I'm in a
market for buying a three million dollar
home okay
and rather than looking at three point
ones and making a 2.9 Million dollar
offer right now I'm going to look at the
fours I'm going to look at the 3 8 I'm
going to look at three sevenths and I'm
going to make a 2-6 offer right now I'm
going to make a 2-7 offer right now and
I'm going to say 2627 cash offer here's
what I got
there's a penthouse in Miami I wanted to
buy 57 for a beautiful place
two years ago that place is a 40 50
million Auto property I made a very
disrespectful offer and I was right by
my offer but they didn't accept my offer
well the property sold for 19 million
bucks a month and a half ago okay that's
a 40 50. that property will sell for 50
million bucks in the next two years
three years 26 26 is about four years
from now but today somebody got it for
19 million bucks this is a building with
all the major celebrities living it's a
very beautiful building one thousand
Biscayne if you put the picture so the
audience can see it it looks like a you
know woman's body the designer was a
woman who designed it and then she
passed away it's a beautiful amazing
property right property value dropped
immensely so watch us today someone's
got a 200 000 watch they're trying to
sell it hey I want 180 for it offer 95.
again people are going to get offended
someone's got a million three million
dollars worth of cards and they can't
sell it they're afraid to put it on an
auction because they don't think it's
going to sell on an auction make a one
seven offer today let them react all
they have to say is you know if you got
cash cash is King if you're trying to by
commercial property today and all you
have to look at is the days of listing
it's been there for nine and a half
months and they're trying to sell it hey
they want three million dollars for the
building offer 2-1 worst thing they're
going to tell you is what no but it
could start the conversation like I said
today you can get away with a
disrespectful offer I'm getting
disrespectful offers right now if you
only saw the offers I'm getting on some
of the stuff and you know what I say to
the person making me a disrespectful
offer I understand I would too but the
difference is I'm not desperate for the
sale so I'm going to sit on the asset I
don't have to sell it but if I'm
somebody that's selling today you have
to assume most people are gradually
running out of cash they were they had
some dry powder you know they had some
powder but they're doing okay with some
you know Savings in cash to have that's
going away and every month that goes by
there's only so much you can act uh if
the average person was a great actor
they'd be in Hollywood but they're not
in Hollywood because they don't know how
to act
which means they may seem confident
today on Instagram maybe a month from
now maybe three months from now maybe
six months from now but if all of a
sudden cash goes from having a few
million in a bank to a million to 600
out to 400 down now you're sitting there
saying I only have nine more months left
you're a little bit quick the first
reaction is get rid of get rid of get
rid of I don't care just sell it I don't
care just sell it I don't care just sell
that property I don't care and when
people get into that motive I don't care
just sell it
people are getting things at a
discounted rate so my recommendation to
you is make some disrespectful offers in
a Christian way but make some
disrespectful love for us I love it I
love it
um let's talk about content and you just
gave an interesting tension between
other Industries and content in these
next few years especially even in
recession we actually personally as soon
as the lockdown started think media's
views doubled our entire YouTube channel
we didn't do a thing different I make
sense people are at home they started
searching for things and so I do think
this is going to be an incredible season
for Content creators and you yourself
have bet on content big you've gone all
in with valuetainment you're starting
shows you're starting uh new
personalities are being recruited you
already have this massively influential
I believe the number one channel on
YouTube for entrepreneurs and uh not
just by the numbers but by the quality
of the content why are you betting so
big on content why am I betting so so
big on content so first of all you know
when you're saying your content crew it
didn't grow just because you were
creating content you were creating good
content right you know people think just
because they create content they're
going to get a hit you're not it's got
to be good content you got to know which
audience you want to attract you have to
figure out a way to differentiate
yourself it's got to be less acting more
you it's got to be authentic either
you're giving me value you're making me
laugh you're making me aware you're
steering the Pod you're controversial
you're doing something to get attention
and there's many ways of doing it but
today
uh uh you know years ago Steve Jobs when
he wanted to make a statement about what
Apple's doing he'd call Hugh Hefner from
Playboy magazine he would say call your
editor-in-chief I want to talk to him he
would call him up and he would say I
want you to interview me I want you to
do is hit piece on me and this story but
he would call Playboy because that was
his audience okay Steve Jobs Playboy's
audience that's what he would do okay
today he doesn't have to do that today
he simply goes like James Corden right
James Corden goes to this restaurant in
New York and all of a sudden he has a
bad day two days ago three days ago and
it's horrible so this is two instances
where he disrespected the waiter waiter
and the waitresses it's the main
restaurant that everybody wants to go to
Balthazar or something like that right
what is the owner of the restaurant do
the owner of the restaurant doesn't call
New York Times or New York Post or LA
Times he goes on his Instagram account
he puts a picture of James Corden on the
bottom describes why he's 86th James
Corden why he's the only one of the only
few people he's 86 and 25 years and he
gives two stories of both times and he
says he can never come back to the
restaurant ever again well today
apparently James Corden called him last
night and had a conversation together
and he officially removed suspending him
and he cannot come back to the
restaurant because he profusely
apologized saying man I apologize for
what I did and they said okay no problem
you can come back to the restaurant so
if he wanted to do that before that
would have taken a longer lifespan
everything is content today everything's
messaging today speed is faster today
controlling the narrative is faster
today uh if 20 years ago I'm building a
business I'm probably more focused on
building the company brand than my brand
the difference between jobs and and Bill
Gates jobs understood his own brand
mattered as much as the company's brand
people didn't really see Bill Gates as a
brand people did see Steve Jobs as a
brand and you saw the similar thing with
Larry Ellison and some of these other
guys and today you know you're seeing
the difference between Bezos and Musk
Bezos at one point was worth more but
people don't know Bezos they don't even
like Bezos why don't they like Bezos why
don't people like them because no one
knows nothing about the guy why do
people like the Elon Musk why do people
like this guy he's louder than basil
shouldn't they not like Elon Musk well
then Elon Musk trained Bezos to realize
hey Bezos you got to get a little bit
more vocal you got to start paying
attention to your brand so what does the
Bezos do Bezos starts showing what he's
doing traveling having fun he posts a
picture with his muscles saying hey come
on Leo say something to my girl in a
joking way then he calls out Joe Biden
because Elon Musk is so vocal about what
he's saying now people are saying hey
his engagement's gone up people are
liking Bezos there's a little bit of
this guy's got guts he's got audacity so
everyone's starting to realize you know
in today's era whether you like it or
not we're all naked there used to be a
town we could all just hide and be quiet
it's not an effective strategy today
because today when somebody doesn't say
anything about anything we see them as
ingenuous when somebody doesn't have an
opinion about things we see them as
they're hiding something versus here's
how I feel about this here's how I feel
about that here's how I feel about this
people are trusting brains more who's
the leader at the top has a position not
necessarily A you know black and white
position but we know you a little bit
versus we know nothing about you because
we don't know whether we should trust
you or not so it's a different world
today of creating con so that's why
we're doing it and for long-term
purposes we feel every brand has a
position they take
um you got some people that make movies
that run sports ESPN documentaries 64.60
that's great you got some people make
you know for superheroes you know you
got Marvel Avengers all this stuff some
that are making movies that's about
comedy fantastic some that are making
movies that's political you know daily
wired they're trying to give their
messaging we're going to be making
movies for the rest of our lives with
value Tim and Media company around
stories of an entrepreneur and the other
Underdog we're going to inject the
spirit of capitalism to people around
the world because without that system
I'd be regular guy today you're starting
multiple shows and you're recruiting
personalities what's your vision is
there an unlimited cap how many podcasts
do you want to start how many shows do
you want to start is it I don't know
organic development or a highly
strategic like you're trying to hit
certain numbers like Starbucks opening
new stores that's a great question so we
just made an offer on an 11 acre land
three weeks ago which is about five
miles away from here we're going to
build a campus to fit 2 000 people
because we're going to create sets shows
you know like a like a Johnny Carson
Jimmy Kimmel you know Jimmy Fallon type
of a set where PP can rotate right now
just about a building over here that we
created you by the way after this
somebody should take you there for you
to see it you you should go see it and
kind of get some b-roll of it you'll see
a wall of fame with people that we
admire with a gold by team A logo there
in a set with five seats camera Galore
16 foot LED TV where you can do your
podcast in front of you there's 300
people live sitting there while you're
doing a live podcast so live audience
butts and seats having drinks liquor
license cigar lines we're creating a
little bit of a man cave type of a
feeling that's going to be black with
Churchill where you're coming in to
watch a fight or you know football game
or you're watching a debate and you're
sitting there having a cigar having a
conversation with another executive or
founder more of a higher end type of
stuff and it's going to turn into a
comedy club but our the 11 acre land
that we're making an offer on it's going
going to be like DreamWorks Warner
Brothers It's a campus our Consulting
business here that you're looking at
this has been growing uh extremely fast
we can't fit people anymore if we had
enough room we'd have 100 people right
now on the Consulting side because that
business has blown up for us in a big
way it's going to end up being one of
the biggest consulting firms in America
because that's our audience
entrepreneurship so now our private
Equity Firm we're making Investments we
did another investment last week into a
company we're very excited about this
new founder that's building an idea that
I'm really excited about what this guy's
going to be doing so we have our private
Equity Firm we have our consulting firm
called the David Consulting we have our
Investment Group that's called the item
Investment Group we have our comedy side
we're going to do our own model of nsnl
we'll do you know movies documentaries
or set that we created over there is to
bring other podcasters where you can
rotate because you can put whatever logo
you want on the LED TV it's not like a
set that's one person you can mix it up
and add additional things that you want
to to set so we we have a very very
long-term Vision on what we want to do
and it's Crystal Clear that quote right
behind you pretty much answers the
question you just asked I'll read the
quote to you it says not one person in
the entire Motion Picture field knows
for certainty what's going to work every
time out it's a guess and if you're
lucky and educated one William Goldman
right so that to me is we have no clue
how we're gonna do what we want to do
but we know exactly why we're doing what
we're doing so the vision is crystal
clear and you know it's easy when you
have a Clear Vision because the right
people show up so we're going to recruit
other podcasters comedians talent that
wants to talk politics talent that wants
to entertain experts on finance it
doesn't matter we're recruiting people
to come down to South Florida and run
with us what's your advice to Founders
leaders somebody that wants to dream a
little bit bigger
um I feel like I love your vision and we
get to draft behind you and learn from
you you you've got so much Vision what's
your advice for recruiting and
attracting leaders to help you build an
Empire as big as you're describing yeah
so so number one is the sooner you know
what you want to build okay so let's
just say you if you're the more you're
winging it the less likely you're going
to find the right people when I was
winging at the right people weren't
showing up the moment I Got Crystal
Clear on what I wanted to do and my
vision was very clear I sat down and I
said here's what I want to do this is
what I'm looking for then I started
telling everybody about what I'm doing
and what I'm looking for and it would
always end with hey Sean listen you got
a few minutes yeah so let me tell you
what I'm working on right now here's
what the vision the company is this is
what we're trying to do this is where
we're going here's what we're thinking
we're going to get there and I want to
know if you know anybody that can help
us with this because I need somebody
that's a CTO I need a chief compliance
officer I need to you know a CEO I need
a president I need to cheat
editor-in-chief do you know anybody just
the other day I'm on the phone and I'm
looking for an editor-in-chief okay for
our news uh uh site that we have
atainment.com so I sit there and what do
I do no joke I sit there I'm trying to
show you some of the people that I
texted you you'd recognize the names
they've texted me back at this point but
I'm I'm texting people and here's my
tech sounds I am looking for a president
of my media company we're hiring another
50 employees between now and the end of
the year if you know anybody that would
make a hell of a president for media
company or an editor-in-chief for our
new site I'd love to speak with somebody
thank you I send 50 messages out half of
them respond back saying I don't know
anybody the other have responded back
saying let me think about it and a
handful of them said I got a couple
names that you got to talk to them
fantastic but my job is now to tell
people what I'm looking for just like
when I was single and I finally realized
I'm ready to get married and I knew what
I wanted as a wife what I wanted her to
look like how I wanted her to be when I
got clear I I started telling everybody
this is what I'm looking for if you know
anybody think of me so everybody's like
hey I've got this girl you know she's
Miss California you know I think you'll
like her you guys got to get together so
we're going I'm like oh it's fantastic
getting along we're good okay here's
another one she's doing the scratch I
like this this one and it's like okay
great then I meet my wife awesome then
we get married now we got four kids now
we're together for 13 years so but
everything is first you want to get
married yes what do you want to look for
in a wife go tell everybody about it
number two what do you want to do with
your vision here's what you want to do
go tell everybody about it so somehow
some way people appear
um and and they'll typically match your
profile like when I met your team in
Vegas
similarizing principles I met that one
girl that had 16 000 Subs on her Channel
who's a teacher trying to teach
homeschooling Heather oh Heather just
really liked her then I started seeing
other guys that you had there Ryan was
there just what a great guy he is the
former baseball player him and his wife
good looking guy could be a model by the
way and he's doing real estate I really
liked him then I started just seeing
who's around you right you're learning
about that but typically whatever values
and principles you'll have you're going
to draw those types of people to your
company
So speaking a little bit deeper on media
I'm curious uh your take on Mr Beast
recently on a podcast the flagrant
podcast revealed that he turned down a
one billion dollar offer for his YouTube
channel and he said I'm clearly not
looking to sell at this point he said
maybe if it was a 10 or 20 billion I
would even consider it for now
um that would make me more comfortable
handing over the keys to my kingdom But
ultimately I think it could be worth way
more I think people on the outside of
what's happening in the YouTube world in
the content world are absolutely shocked
by that but from your perspective do you
think that uh he made a bad call or do
you think that he's exactly right he's
way undervaluing uh What It Is Well I
mean a couple things one your business
is worth whatever the market is willing
to pay you we don't have the details of
what was offered to him but let's do
some basic math okay so I just pulled up
his channel his most viewed video is 293
million views it's a 25 minute video
that's the 456 thousand dollar squid
game that he did which was all over the
place and one note about that as well is
he's also doing multiple different
channels quality dubbed so his most
viewed video squid game is actually
higher in another language yeah and and
I'm a word so but let's do this together
so Super Bowl commercial you do 30
seconds what are you paying 5.2 million
dollars give or take right
and Super Bowl gets roughly a hundred
million views okay so if we take 300
million people watching the Super Bowl
which is the number here not including
all the other stuff which means a
60-second clip in this 25 minute video
is what
16 million dollars okay so if he's able
to get a billion views because it's in
other languages then that means that's
now a 50 million dollar one video on
that number then you take that I don't
know how many videos he's got if we go
over here and we see how many videos is
uploaded he's got total 17 billion views
I'll just do the number on 17 billion
views we can do together right now on
just one channel okay let's do this
together 17 billion views divided by 100
million because that's what Super Bowl
claims so that's 170 times
5 million bucks okay
minimum that that thing is worth 850
million dollars so one channel so I've
never even been asked this question nor
have I done the math his one channel
alone has generated a minimum of 850
million dollars and I'm calculating only
one commercial so assume on each video
he can do Five Sixty Second commercials
if we go to five on that that's 4.2
billion dollars that he has in his in
his channel so I uh uh and then add it
to all the other channels that he has I
think he's right 10 to 20 billion
dollars the right number and YouTube
revenue and also the commercial spots
and then also and I I'm not sure if in
the deal he's got Beast Burger now
because I think it might have been for
his Empire he's got a restaurant oh my
God the entire Empire they offered a
billion I'm not sure but that's that's
what he was he was saying this is I
haven't I I heard about it people ask me
but if it's for the whole thing and does
he come with it and how many years does
he come with it and how many minimum
Clips is he going to do per month how
many videos is it going to do if if all
of that comes together I think he's
right it's a 10 billion no I wouldn't be
selling you less than 10 billion yeah
and and he has a chocolate bar and
that's already in Walmart now yeah and
so even off the momentum of his brand I
mean of course there would be
diminishing results but yeah that's
fascinating so what do you think that
speaks to in terms of do you think that
there's still a big disconnect between
the old media world and the New Media
World respecting a content creator like
Mr Beast and traditional media still
being uh the the weights are not
balanced in terms of maybe understanding
what this is worth or do you think it is
accurate uh okay so I mean but none of
that is anything new meaning I'm
Armenian and I'm a Syrian born and
raised in Iran right I've done very well
for myself I've made a few hundred
million dollars okay but if I go sit
down with my mom who's Armenian she'll
talk about one of her friends uh
daughters that got a four-year degree
and I don't have a four-year degree so
to her success is a four-year degree to
her success is being a doctor I don't
have a PhD I will never have any plans
of getting a PhD or Masters or a
bachelor's so that doesn't change you
know what what what is the difference
between a person who goes to Harvard and
gets a degree from Harvard where on the
wall it says Harvard but they're making
130 a year versus a person who went to a
community college graduated from a small
school and built a business that sells
it for 1.2 billion in the eyes of an
educator Harvard gets more credibility
in the eyes of a doer Forbes 400 you
know all the other stuff of course
you're going to look at the guy that's
generated Revenue but media is getting a
black eye and people like him are not
slowing down and this is just the
beginning by the way what he's been able
to build and it's going to be
interesting as he ages and turns 30 or
35 or 40 is he going to duplicate
himself and bring other people to get
others to do what he does because he has
a personality but he doesn't have Jimmy
Fallon's personality he doesn't have
Logan Paul's personality he doesn't have
Jake Paul's personality meaning his
model is duplicatable Logan Paul is not
duplicatable Jake Paul is not
duplicatable Tate not duplicatable rock
not duplicatable Mr Beast very
duplicatable so imagine if this guy goes
and recruits 20 30 40 other 16 year old
18 year olds and he owns 80 percent of
the company and he teaches them how to
do it and then they go take off could
this guy in the next 20 years be worth a
half a trillion dollars it could very
likely happen to a guy like him and he's
24. and he's 24 exactly
um
when you look at media right now what
are your most important Platforms in
order for you strategically
for me strategically obviously it's
YouTube at the top for me why
um because I'm a long form
uh because I'm um you know I do my Clips
in a way where I have multiple channels
I'm building it on so we got
valuetainment we got value timing short
clips we got pbd podcast we got VT money
we got valtayman uh Russian we got
Jedediah Bila so that's where invitemic
comedy is so that's that's where our
main driver is uh Instagram is playing a
very big role right now Instagram is
like Vinnie downstairs he just put up a
clip on Instagram funny clip just being
silly in the office it's an 11 second
clip it's got 6.9 million views on
Instagram okay great that's number two
for you by Instagram I would say
Instagram would be their
um Facebook is probably three Tick Tock
is good for a lot of people we were
growing very rapidly on Tick Tock and
you know every other video would be a
hundred thousand views two hundred
thousand views the last time we had a
hundred thousand view was uh 350 videos
ago so we don't know what's going on
though and we even bumped up the quality
of Clips so the same Clips we put on
Tick Tock gets 2 000 views but we'll put
it on Instagram and it'll get you know
two million views eight million views
six million views so Tick Tock to us
it's a little bit tricky I don't want to
get into what what uh that could be to
read some of the content I talk about is
not politically correct I call out I
challenge so uh some places that may or
may not perform very well but I would I
would put those would be the lists if we
do dig a little bit deeper on Tick Tock
what are some of your predictions
um they recently they're going to
e-commerce and they're opening
warehouses they're opening warehouses
and Amazon's backyard to expand
e-commerce
um they are now doing
still photos they're doing longer form
Clips still photos like Instagram
and Washington Post just did a big deep
dive in five years the app once written
off is a silly dance video fad has
become one of the most prominent disgust
distrusted technically sophisticated and
geopolitically complicated juggernauts
on the internet a phenomenon that has
secured an unrivaled grasp on culture
and everyday life and intensified the
conflict between the world's biggest
superpower no app has grown faster past
a billion users and more than a hundred
million of them are in the United States
roughly a third of the country so what
are your opinions on Tick Tock I wonder
if demographics come into play Maybe
certainly politics come into play but if
we do actually dive into the world of
tick tock it's a force it's coming
really strong you've got Trump wants to
shut it down and it's very controversial
but it's also absolutely massive as a
strategist and as a predictor of culture
what are your what's your view on Tick
Tock so for example I'll give you three
different uh point of views what phone
do you use I think what do I have iPhone
what do you have iPhone okay so that's
not good you know one of my guys I just
called him right now Jose I was on the
phone with them and I said uh I called
them back he says hey uh where you at
I'm at T-Mobile why are you at T-Mobile
because my phone shut down yesterday he
has an iPhone where he was with Droid
for 15 years he barely switched over to
iPhone right
we need competition and iPhone doesn't
have competition that's not good for you
and me Google's phone is not strong
enough droid's getting crushed right now
Blackberry has been dead you know we
need somebody that comes out that comes
out and competes with this or else
they're very very close to Monopoly Here
the way they're grown right now and
that's not a good thing for the market
at all right so that's one two uh if
that happens what's Instagram's
competition if tick tock's out nobody so
you need Instagram to have a competition
would you say Snapchat their stock is on
85 Snapchat is not Instagram it's a very
different model than Instagram is so it
wouldn't work out who's going to compete
against Instagram Facebook it's the same
company owned by meta so LinkedIn
linkedin's not going to compete Twitter
Twitter's not going to compete they try
to do stories and they kind of went away
from it they have it a little bit but
they're not really advertising it to try
to compete with Instagram so I want a
competitor to Instagram everybody wins
because Tick Tock forces Instagram to
get your views up more audience seeing
it but if tick tock goes away Instagram
is going to say lower back down to seven
percent and charge people let them do
ads so they can make money so tick
tock's the reason why Facebook's values
dropped where you know Mark Zuckerberg's
lost 60 billion dollars in network just
this year tick tock's getting in his way
so okay so let's see what this is going
to look like so that's that part
capitalism kind of needs to work and
Tick Tock helps Tick Tock is the least
trusted app in America by a lot of
people politically Left Right middle
doesn't matter they do not trust Tick
Tock of course people don't like
Zuckerberg or they don't like Dorsey or
they don't like some of these names
because their names and they have
control of these organizations but the
challenge with Tick Tock is with the way
they're going they're one or two
presidents away from being banned for
four years
Trump almost did it and DeSantis could
do it I don't think anybody from the
other side would do it but I think Trump
or DeSantis I would not be would you be
surprised if the sentence becomes
president and says hey we looked at the
numbers unless if you give us this
report you're banned until you give us
these reports
so then what's going to happen when he
does that uh the media on the other side
is going to get the youth to be
complaining about hating Trump to lose
that vote but the youth doesn't vote
anyway so they're not going to care
about that they're just loud but they
don't vote India banned 100 apps from
their country Tick Tock being one of
them Tick Tock is not allowed in India
you can't go use tick tock in India and
China hates India and India does not
trust China and India was able to stand
up towards China so yeah these guys are
one or two
presidents away from being banned in
America they're getting as much Intel as
they can right now but even when the CEO
of tick tock USA was asked questions
that are you reporting back to China he
wouldn't answer the question three four
five different attempts would eventually
have to say yes we have to bike dance or
whatever the company's name is called
bite something they have to report all
the data back over to them because
that's the company that they report to
so there are one or two presidents away
from being banned by
2024-2025. for you are you hesitant to
invest in Tick Tock one of the
interesting things that they're also
building out is search functionality and
apparently gen Z is using Tick Tock as a
preferred search engine over Google and
the SEO aspects of tick tock are rising
and so in light of them may be
completely getting banned
um also if your results are not
happening there it may just be a
strategy to say we're just going to test
everywhere but for you do you see any
reason to invest more into that because
of of maybe reaching the Next Generation
or are you neutral anti or or seeing
strategy to lean in I would because I my
My Philosophy is to convert or change
the way of thinking right for you to say
never thought about it that way you know
what I'll be an entrepreneur I never
thought about it though I guess
capitalism is not as bad as I thought it
was never thought about it that we
respect rich people are not that bad
never thought about it that way I should
go learn how to sell never thought so
that's my approach to get anybody to say
never thought of a give some perspective
so I want to be on all platforms to be
able to get the audience and and help
them out with that my own uh motive that
I have just like everybody has but you
have to realize just six years ago seven
five years ago we had a phone company
competing in America and it was a
hundred billion Auto phone company do
you remember that phone company's name
Huawei oh yeah when's the last time you
heard you heard the name Huawei they got
shot not in a long time yeah got a CFO
they told them not to do business with
Iran and the CFO the daughter of the
owner of the company was in Canada and
she did some dealings with Iran and it's
like hey you're done guess what Huawei
is out of the states and you were
starting to see people having Huawei
phones because Huawei was tapping into
and trying to get Intel like this it's
gone so listen do whatever you can to
get a lot of eyeballs but don't forget
uh people were addicted to vine where is
Vine it's been replaced by Tick Tock
it's been replaced by Instagram
everything's going to be replaced by
something new it's all going to be fine
but what they're trying to do to get the
Intel and you know the dirty place that
Tick Tock is doing it's going to catch
up to them it's just a matter of time as
we land the plane Adobe did a study
called the future of creativity study
and it revealed that 165 million content
creators have joined the crater economy
since 2020. so there's a massive wave in
inspiring content creators young
people's greatest aspiration they're
saying is not to be an astronaut but
it's to be a YouTuber
what is The Good the Bad and the Ugly of
social media I hear your vision on the
good of you can reach people and get a
good message to them but in your Deep
dive conversation even with Andrew Tate
I think he mentioned I'm not sure if you
agree about the harmful
nature of social media just scrolling
shortening attention spans
um and and just kind of The Good the Bad
and the Ugly for conflicted parents for
business owners who are wanting to maybe
do good but also have these red flags
that social media presents
so
um you know historically people have
done a lot to get 15 seconds of Fame
right a lot to do 15 seconds of Fame
whether it's taking out a president or
you know getting out there and hurting
somebody or fire or doing something to a
building there's just a lot of things
that people will do for fame for
whatever reason that big screen for
people to say I saw you on TV I saw you
on a video I saw you on this video that
went viral oh my oh you saw me am I
famous oh my God this feels amazing I'm
noticed right when you walk into some
place oh hey Sean how are you oh hi I
watch your content I love your content I
appreciate what you're doing oh hey this
so that feeling is a form of a high
right that you get you are being noticed
you're contributing there's some Fame
there's some accolades
we feed that naturally people feel
recognition we are driven by recognition
the most humble person in the world
Mother Teresa became very famous that's
recognition okay she got got a form of
recognition Billy Graham the recognition
in his eyes could be I baptized 210
million people in my lifetime he goes
and speaks in Korea one and a half
million people show up if you post a
picture Billy Graham Korea one and a
half million people look at the audience
makes no sense these are people that
don't speak English they show because
he's shown up it's a form of a
recognition that he had right okay so
where am I going with this
this is my concern I have a few friends
that are in Hollywood who are a-listers
who have done very well for themselves
now when he when we're talking they'll
say listen man are you kidding me
politically you think I'm like them I'm
not like them I'm this this this this
that so how about that person he's also
thinks like this but how come he
supports publicly this person and that
person
says for obvious reasons you know he is
not going to get the jobs he's not going
to get the eyeballs he's not going to
keep getting those big movies if he's
aligned with those guys look what
happened to you know Clinic you know not
clinics but he has no money so he
doesn't give a [ __ ] but look what
happened to Mel Gibson look what
happened to this verse look what
happened to that person they never look
what happened to Vince Vaughn Vince
Vaughn did one thing with Ron Paul what
happened to him afterwards used to see
Vince Vaughn in every single thing Vince
Vance Wonder loved favorite actors what
happened to him he all of a sudden
disappeared when they go into this box
of how they feel right and then Netflix
changed the game and all these other
guys Otts were like listen screw you I
don't need to beg you know Weinstein
anymore I don't need to beg all these
guys but this is where I'm going with it
sometimes being so concerned about
eyeballs
forces you to
put eyeballs over what you stand for
where it's recognition more than True
Values and principles
if you can manage that
and still stay true to your character
and your values and principles and not
compromise that no matter how many
eyeballs you get good for you but if
we're gonna go in the direction where
164 million what the number use 165
million content creators creators
and your goal is to measure success
based on subscribership based on AdSense
based on views well what does that
really mean does that mean you're gonna
have to compromise to do anything to get
the eyeballs and subscribers so that's
the only thing that concerns me a little
bit that if that's recognition
you know there's anything I can do to
get 15 seconds of Fame are you willing
to go that far I'm not I'm not willing
to do because now you're lying now
you're being somebody you're not just to
protect the agency that's representing
you you're with WME and WME if they find
that you said this oh my God you're
going to lose that sponsorship with
Sprite and that sponsorship I don't know
so you know that's my only concern about
it I I don't think it's anything new
where people are afraid of saying what
they say because somebody's in their
pocket that they're paying them so they
don't want to say anything bad about
them uh so does it produce more fake
people or real people we won't find out
for another 10 20 30 years but if you
were to ask me that'd be my number one
concern last question on your 44th
birthday if you could look back at a
young entrepreneur call it in their 20s
building a company uh and especially for
our community a lot of people we're
calling them content entrepreneurs it's
the idea that you can build a media
business as a solopreneur so many
different ways to make Revenue what are
just some of the uh advice and maybe
this reflect Collective day that you
would just give to a young entrepreneur
10 15 years back for a contentpreneur or
an entrepreneur running a real business
as an operator let's go content okay
okay so content to entrepreneurs so if
it's content entrepreneur you know it
would be one word and it's alignment let
me explain what I mean by this alignment
so
if if you can be yourself and create
content
so you're not acting I think you're
winning
but if you have to play somebody else to
get eyeballs where you're acting and
that's what gets the eyeballs where The
UU won't get the real eyeballs I think
that's a conflict that's a little bit of
a conflict so everything to me is what
happens for example let's just say I'm
I'm telling you you got to live by these
10 rules these are the 10 values and
principles Sean you gotta live by this
and I'm your dad and I'm telling you
this and I don't live by that deep down
inside I have conflict and I have
internal conflict which is the worst
kind of conflict forget about the
conflict I have with you I have internal
conflict because when there's internal
conflict everybody runs you feels it
right because you're not living in
aligned life to when I when I was
creating content and I'm trying to be
something I'm not I'm like not only am I
not enjoying it but I'm just it's not
also doing good so I don't care to be
that listen I can't help myself I love
talking about politics I'm going to keep
doing that I love capitalism I'm going
to keep doing that I love
entrepreneurship I'm going to talk about
that I'll love you know interviewing
people who are in certain industries
that I have interest over I'm going to
keep pursuing that topic and then if
there's an audience for it fantastic if
there's not it's all good but trying to
compromise who you are on the big screen
to get eyeballs versus
my biggest suggestion would be try to
match these two together and then listen
it doesn't mean you don't get creative
you know you want to get creative or
have a board here we'll sit down like
you know I had a meeting with a couple
of my content creators on talent and I'm
sitting there talking to one of them I'm
saying listen why are you still talking
about this well because it's what I
stand for there's no way I cannot talk
about this I said listen that's nine
months ago people have moved on it's
over what other interests do you have so
I sat and had a two-hour meeting with
one of my content creators and I said
what bothers you we wrote it down 20
things what do you love we wrote it down
what do you hate we wrote it down when
you were a kid what interest did you
have what do you know a lot about that I
don't know do you know a lot about the
Yankees do you know a lot about the
history of animals do you like lions did
you grow up as a tell me what hair what
do you know about middle league did you
study theology do you know a lot about
politics do you know a lot about what
the law what do you know a lot about
yesterday I'm sitting on my son my 10
year old son tells me he says daddy do
you know what that uh there's certain
sea bass that you eat that has a poison
that if you eat this sea bass hot
becomes cold and cold becomes hot that
you can't even have ice in your drinks
because your mouth will feel like you're
on fire I'm like what are you talking
about he says no I'm telling you like
this guy's trying to pull a prank so I
go and I research I'm like this kid is
right there's a poison that what did you
learn about this I read it in a book so
my son loves reading the 5 000 fact
books right so if he wanted to create
content he could create a fact thing he
can do different things so you know if
if you can figure out a way to improve
yourself as a content creator where
talking to another guy yesterday who's
got 950 000 subs and he's been around
that number for about six months you
know how frustrating it is to be at 9
15. sure very annoying because you're
kind of like dude I'm right there at a
million but I'm like I'm annoyed right
and he's reached the limit of his
content
he's reached for his audience they don't
have interest on the same things he
talked about for the last two years
because his content is limited based on
life experiences and he no longer has
any life experiences to share that's new
they've heard all of it in 200 episodes
so now what does he do he has to figure
out a way because the audience is like
we got everything from you already now
you're trying to give us something if he
doesn't adjust he's going to be a
YouTube channel that got a million Subs
based on the videos he did not any more
interest on anything new it's a very
emotional place to be when you're there
because you're no longer getting that
attention so it is an emotional job it
is tough it is draining your insecurity
is going to come out you're going to be
going on streaks where you feel like
nobody cares anymore you're forgotten
about but if you constantly try to
recreate yourself while still staying
true to your values and principles new
audience will constantly show up Pastor
David we thank you for your time today
where can people go and uh learn more
about what you're doing I want to
recommend next five moves business plan
Workshop had a huge impact in our
business but social media as we end I
would say I just launched a new app
called manect and the reason why I
launched manec the app is because one
time a lawyer and I had a seven minute
call together he built me for 30 minutes
I'm like why am I paying you for 30
minutes I call them and say I don't want
to pay for 30 minutes it was a seven
minute call he says Pat minutes roll up
I said I want to pay you by the minute
he says no lawyer charges by the minute
and this was five years ago I said if I
ever come out with an app it's going to
be an app where I can pay lawyers
influencers doctors by the minute
so minute is minute is do you have a
minute to connect hence minute right so
we just launched the app connect if you
want to have a 15 minute face time with
Andrew Tate you can do it on minute if
you want to have a 15 minute face time
with me or just ask me a question I
respond on a video or Kiyosaki or Chas
palm and Terry or Rick Macy Rick Matthew
is the tennis coach for the Williams
Sister it doesn't matter so many experts
are on there that can be found on minute
so I would I would say if there's any
app to go to first month we have 30 000
downloads and a bunch of experts taking
advantage of the questions in the live
so I would say go download the app
connect and you'll find us there thank
you appreciate you thank you